[MUSIC]
A lot of my work is around
corporate income shifting,
which is one way that companies
respond to tax incentives globally.
So if you think of a company that has all
of its income across all of its operations
around the world, it's going to be taxed
on that income in each jurisdiction.
And so if there are different tax
rates in different jurisdictions,
which we know there are, then it's in
the best interest of a company from a tax
planning perspective to try to report
more profits in low-tax jurisdictions and
less profits and high tax jurisdictions.
[MUSIC]
I like to think of it as, first and
foremost, an operational decision.
So where as a company do you put
your footprint around the world
such that you're creating value
in different jurisdictions.
And this is something that gets a lot
of attention in particular with
intellectual property,
patents, and things like that.
Putting those in low-tax jurisdictions,
sometimes called tax havens.
And that allows a lot
of the profits to move,
be reported in those
low-tax jurisdictions.
But it's a broader analysis than
just intellectual property.
It's all of the functions, risks,
and assets of the company.
And so the operational decision is
figuring out a tax efficient footprint.
And then on top of that,
you can layer an accounting decision.
And that is, now that I put
some patents in say, Ireland,
how much of a royalty do all of the other
parts of the company have to pay
to my Irish subsidiary for the right
to exploit that intellectual property?
And that fundamentally,
it's an economic question, but
it gets into the accounting
space of exactly how we want
to assign a price, called a transfer
price, between these two subsidiaries.
And where does that allow us to report
our profits from a tax perspective?
[MUSIC]
There's a global set of rules, and each
country has its own set of rules too for
how you're supposed to come
up with what that price is.
And the fundamental principle that we
operate in globally, not all countries,
but most countries these days is
called the Arms Link Standards.
So it's supposed to be a price that
you would observe out on the open
market between two completely
unrelated parties.
So if you and I were transacting for
the sale of shoes or whatever it is right,
that would be the price as long as
it's at a similar level of the market.
So wholesale versus retail
in a similar economy.
You can take into account nuances like,
developing economies and
foreign exchange rates and
things like that.
But it's supposed to be as if
we're operating at arm's length.
[MUSIC]
The problem with that Is that
a lot of the services and
products that companies are transacting
with amongst their own subsidiaries
are not the same types of things
that unrelated parties transact.
So it's not often the case that
a company that exploits its
own intellectual property
around the world,
is going to also license that out to
unrelated parties as one example.
Another example is you
think of a CEO providing
high level strategic management for
all of the operations worldwide.
That person is not also providing those
services for competitors for example.
So it can be very difficult to
observe an arm's length price.
And that's what provides a lot
of discretion to companies,
to try to establish a price
substantiated defend it.
But also a price that's going to work for
best for them from a tax perspective.
And this is the big question that
were seeing these days international,
a fundamental question
about transfer pricing.
Should arm's length be the right
standard or should it be
more closely aligned with where
the physical footprint of the firm is.
So discounting intellectual property a
little bit from how much it matters today,
and focusing more on where sales are made,
where the customers are, and
where the actual employees are.
[MUSIC]
It seems tempting, I think, for
countries to set their tax policies
in a way to try to mitigate this on
a unilateral basis where they're
acting on their own best interest.
But given globalization and
just the increasing amount of dealings
that are happening across borders.
I don't think we get to
a long lasting answer,
until we get countries cooperating
trying to harmonize tax laws.
Doesn't have to be the same rate,
but at a minimum,
we need to agree on how these cross-border
transactions should be priced,
where profits should be recognized.
And until we do that,
you're going to have companies and
individuals taking
advantage of differences.
[MUSIC]
There's a lot of research indicating
that companies are shifting income.
They are making operational and
accounting decisions to move
income out of high-tax locations and
into low-tax jurisdictions.
What's interesting about one of the
studies I have is that a lot of the other
research out there ignores one major
tax strategy that companies can take.
And that is taking advantage of
their subsidiaries with losses.
Which is a really, really important
tax strategy to companies.
When we include this important
strategy we find that
the size of the affect is actually
much larger than we thought before.
Actually all of the research out there
could underestimate the amount that
corporations are engaging in this income
shifting activity by as much as 50%.
Which is a very big difference.
So there's a lot more of it
going on than we thought and
it's a lot bigger than we thought.
[MUSIC]
What does it mean to pay your fair share,
whether it's a corporation or
an individual, what does that look like?
What does it look like to be
a good corporate citizen or
a good citizen of your
country where you owe taxes.
And it's a tough question.
Because companies have a profit motive.
They have shareholders
that they're beholden to.
And there's a perspective,
the shareholder perspective of the firm,
that companies should be maximizing
value for their shareholders.
There's also a stakeholder perspective
which is that we're all stakeholders in
this society that we've built and so
we should all pay our fair share.
And I think the two perspectives aren't
necessarily mutually exclusive but
it's very difficult to answer
the question what is fair because
it's inherently subjective.
If we know that companies
are doing this and
we can estimate how much they're doing it,
and we're starting to look at some of
the consequences of that is, it's natural
to ask what should the policies be.
To think about what could be done to
mitigate the behavior if we think
it should be mitigated or just generally
how should corporations be responding,
is there a policy tool that we can
use to try to get that response,
instead of what they're doing now.
[MUSIC]